the first item uh welcome everybody to
the meeting the first item is
attendances
uh which uh should be all recorded
electronically i've had one apology
from councillor churchill um have we had
any other apologies
no chair everybody else is here okay
uh item two is minutes of the meeting
21st of january
uh 2021 um
take it we've read them and can we
accept that as a true and correct record
yes jeff yeah right uh item three the
main item of the
business for the meeting is the covid 19
licensing team
service plan extension of
interim measures from the first of april
2021 so we we've basically gone through
a year of doing these interim
arrangements
in basically three month phases and
we've now
sort of completed a year and we're
looking forward to the rest of
this year bearing in mind we all know
when the lockdown
get the sorry the lockdown release dates
are but
things aren't going to be getting back
to normal quickly so
i think we've got a a couple of uh
proposals on the
um on the medical
forum and uh the uh not issuing
new licenses so uh take it joanna you're
gonna
speak to speak to this yeah sure thank
you chad
um thank you so the members of
everywhere has just been stated that
we've been
um over the last several months um
asking the subcommittee to approve
a number of temporary proposals to allow
the delivery
of the service um during the current
situation um
so this report is a part of that ongoing
of those ongoing interim measures
um and we're seeking today um approval
for two
further proposals and the first relates
to the council's requirement
that all licensed drivers must at
regular intervals provide a medical
certificate
um at its meeting on the 17th of
december
2020 the subcommittee agreed to allow
drivers
who were unable to provide a medical
certificate
to complete an online self-certification
which we agreed would be valid until the
31st
of march 2021 and then after this date
we would be requiring
that they provide a certificate signed
by their own doctor but we did say we
would review that
nearly the time so i think obviously
this is the time to do it
unfortunately we've still we're still
having reports
that it's anecdotal accounts that
some drivers are still experiencing
difficulty
accessing their gp surgeries or their
gps are refusing
to do taxi driving medicals in the
current situation
so it's still the view of officers that
the best option is a medical report
completed by the driver's own gp
however we do recognize that this may
not be possible
in the current circumstances so having
reviewed the options available
what we're proposing is that we still
require
in the first instance that the driver
get a medical from their gp if they can
um if they're unable to do that um
because i don't know the gp may be
limiting face-to-face appointments or
you know he's unable to undertake
examinations at that time
we're proposing to continue to allow
drivers to complete the online medical
self-certification and that that would
be valid up to the 30th
of june 2021 so we're extending it again
for another
three months obviously
gp surges are still going to be busy in
the next several months
and it may still be difficult for
drivers to get medical certificates
um in which case we're then kind of
proposing a gradual return hopefully to
um the full medical from their own gp
but what was
what we were we're gonna start with is
requiring that from the first of july
that they that we cease the
self-certification scheme
and um the driver must provide
something more robust so we are
proposing that we require at least
a medical completed by a private medical
company
um who has seen a copy of
a summary of the driver's medical
history
now the driver will have to get that
from the surgery
but they can take that to a private
medical company
be interviewed by a doctor who will view
their medical
um history um and
make a determination about their
suitability
and what we're saying is that that would
be
acceptable up to the end of the year
so the 31st of december 2021
after which we would hope to return to
our normal position of
drivers being required to get a full
medical further from their own gp who
has their full
medical history so that's the first
proposal
the second relates to the decision of
the subcommittee
at the beginning of the pandemic to
suspend our stages
of the new driver application process
this was obviously because we couldn't
safely facilitate the knowledge test
um or induction course because they're
normally classroom-based
um we do continue to try and develop
this
remote solution but we've we've been
having a number of obstacles to
progressing that
and until that's in place and whilst we
still have to comply with the social
distancing rules
we're asking that the suspension of the
new drive application process
continue um until at least
at least the end of september 2021
so those are the two proposals in the
report for your consideration i'm happy
to answer any questions members may have
okay thank you joanne so the new driver
applications we're going to review that
before
well presumably the september meeting
are we yes
um yes if i didn't say so before yeah we
would review it
again then hopefully we'll have more
we'll have more progress either on an
online solution or
if i'm honest i think
because it's all going to be dependent
on us being having
um a venue to host
the test because even if we're doing an
online test i think this still has to be
an element of supervision
um we can't allow the drivers to be
doing the test
from home so um
we still expect that there would still
be that kind of classroom
environment and if if we can't act we
can't provide that
we might struggle um to start the
process again
in september but hopefully either the
town hall will be able to facilitate
that or other venues
will be opening up where we can actually
um host those kinds of events
so we'll review yeah that the intention
will be to review in september
let's ask the questions here on this
yeah
in chat i think we should stay with chat
because we can go in order
sorry yeah
right sophie
thanks joanne thank you very much for
that report can i just ask
and i've got full insights of this i'm
just thinking about the remote solutions
what um what's been the sort of
challenge with that really
um because obviously you know we do
manage a lot of roommates i do a lot of
teaching remotely i'm just wondering
what it has been it has been the it
supports if i'm honest
right um so i must have been liaising
with the it development team
um because we're gonna be developing
something from
scratch really we've got obviously we've
got um
tests written we've got test papers
written and we've got
um an induction course which we produce
which we present
so it was just i thought it would be a
fairly simple
process of actually converting that into
some kind of online solution um but
we've just been damied by it development
they've obviously had a lot of demands
on their time
which i understand um
and whether so whenever we've engaged
they've obviously had other priorities
unfortunately
um we also have been engaging with the
safeguarding team because we wanted them
to write
this online um induction course
including all these
things around safeguarding and again and
they wanted to engage with they were
experiencing i.t problems
in order to develop that side of things
as well
so um we've now started to think about
we've suggested
looking at you know the um the staff
training
um facility that we have you know we
have to do um our
annual training that's that's produced
by
whether we can use that as um
as a platform so that's what we've been
asking can
can can it look into that and
safeguarding can they look into that
option
so that was the last communication you
had with them
yeah so yeah but still
as i say i still think even if we had
that facility
that would help us in terms of avoiding
having to mark physical papers yeah
and so on so that would protect staff
but i do still think that this is this
issue of supervision and we need
would need um
rooms where people could sit and have
access to computers
um to do it and there isn't anywhere at
the moment available
even in our training rooms which there's
a very limited number i think we have
like 10 computers don't you in
one of the training rooms so that would
mean having to
have sessions you know
running every hour every day
just to get through the numbers of
people who are waiting so
lots of lots of um factors to consider
at the moment so yeah no i just thought
ask i mean it is difficult because in my
day job you know both in the national
health and
in um in education obviously we've had
to take
loads and loads of work online and it is
really you know it is challenging and
you do need
mega i.t support to do but it is it is
possible to do you know where
so you know that would have thought that
that could have been something but you
know
i i i first had experience i know
it is difficult um and the issue of
supervision is is hard as well isn't it
know that these people are generally who
they say they are doing the work don't
you
yeah yeah now i just wondered yeah i'd
pursue with it because i think it could
work couldn't it
it could and i think that's it is that
this is our ambition that that would be
the way forward
yeah we would have it online anyway even
though
we would still have to have people come
into the wherever we're hosting it
and sit at a desk and do it and be
supervised but
everything would and it would be marked
automatically then that would have all
that
all that in place yeah yeah no thank you
very much that's the ambition
great thank you okay dylan and then
michael
oh thanks so much yeah just a question
around the the medical
uh can you just remind us how long the
medical is valid for is it for the
length of that
license period that they've been given
or
so our rule is that um you have to have
a medical when you first apply to us
and whatever age you are you have to
have a satisfactory medical
and from that date every five years
you must have another one and that's the
case all the way up to when you reach 65
and at that age we require you to have a
medical every year
every annually
so every five years is the normal rule
yeah and
uh our ticket there's not many over 65
drive uh
license we don't have many we don't have
many one or two
yes there are there are drivers who have
to
give it annual annual medicals um but
a diminishing number of drivers after
65.
because i don't believe they're not
cheap these anti-medicals are they
they're not
they're not um and that you know our
proposal is we're currently only except
we only require a group one medical
which is out of step with the rest of
greater manchester
and um the proposal is that um
drivers will have to provide a group two
medical
if our you know our taxi new taxi
licensing
um policy is approved yeah um
that's absolutely even more expensive
because it's a you know it's the medical
that is done by
um lorry drivers and bus drivers
it's the dvla group two medical i
suppose that'll be similar to like the
ones that the pilots have in airline
pilots because they
check the heartbeat at heart rates and
rhythms and everything well i don't know
if a class a taxi driver is like a pilot
but
no no but i mean there's still public uh
transporting and i'm not sure what the
level is there
obviously but you know the more
obviously responsibility you have the
more
in the test says but group two is the
recognized
um test for road haulers
and yeah because i'm connected with
aviation you see so i know a little bit
about it oh right right so today
are they required to do a group two
medical lending well uh
yeah they have annual medicals and uh
irrespective of age and it's only at the
age of 60.
yeah we would still only be proposing
every five years so it's not
but after 65 yeah it's still an annual i
don't know
[Music]
and also the benefit of the pilot is
that he's got a co-pilot next to him so
if anything you know he's going to feel
anything
which you wouldn't have with the driver
yeah
classic incident when we had that that
bus driver who went straight into that
uh
exactly yeah yeah yeah yeah and it's one
reason why
and obviously we put in place the
self-certification
system because at the time you know
people would
simply weren't able to um to go to their
um gps um
um that has relaxed a little bit let you
know some gps i mean
it's not that we've got lots of drivers
who can't get a medical
um it's just that some practices are
saying to drivers we're not going to do
them
as a priority or we're certainly not
going to do them at this time
but it's been a year now and i do we do
think that we need to
start looking at something a bit more
robust than a cell certification
um and that possibly the next step is
to at least for them to go and visit a
doctor with them
a summary of their medical history and
we get something a bit more robust
from from from that doctor um
never going to be as good as you getting
it from your own doctor and
obviously we still want to press for
that um but
um it's we feel it's a bit we've got
this duty obviously to ensure that
people
are medically fit to be driving so i
think at some stage we're going to have
to start
um asking um you know
for more stricter um checks
that's that's happening now that um
doctors are giving um
like a brief summary you can get one you
can get
but you can get both a a summary which
shouldn't take
too long a few days possibly or we could
ask for a
full history which could take several
weeks to get from your
practice you can get them you're
entitled to you know it's your
medical
yeah but what i think we will be would
insist on is that
because we have been approached by a
number of medical companies saying we
can do this for you
um and what i'd want for them to say
that they had seen
either person and they'd seen a medical
summary um and confirmed that
um they were satisfied of their
suitability
well what do we do if somebody has a
medical incident
during the five-year period are they
presumably are obliged to declare it if
it's serious enough
are there some rules about that if you
know somebody quite young could have
some medical
in the middle of his five-year period
one of the things that we
um have needed to change in our
regulations
is our conditions is that they must
notify us if they get a medical
if they do you know develop a medical
condition
it's actually um i'm afraid to say
not a condition on the license at the
moment so that is definitely going to
change
um obviously we would expect people to
to do that but it's
so currently not an actual requirement
on their conditions of license
so so they wouldn't be in breach of
their conditions of license there would
be other issues but
um you know we they wouldn't be in
breach of that license so
that need that does need to change yeah
obviously
if it's imperial their livelihood would
be a temptation wouldn't they too
yes exactly yes of course yeah
will that change when we go to sort of
one set of conditions with
all the greater so we've got our own
conditions
but they're very similar you know they
might be we have a basic
core set of conditions for each type of
license
and then if we want to ask to be
stricter they can be
and so yeah they're very they're all
very similar at their core
and including these conditions like this
and we've agreed
about medicals and dbs's and so on
um but if we wanted to add a little
something a bit more stricture around
some condition we can do so we have that
that flexibility
but we all agree about um the
requirement for
um there to be a medical we disagree on
um how often they should be because some
authorities
don't require one until they're over
um i think it's 45 so they have one when
they get
licensed and then they don't need to do
another one until they're 45.
and that's that's a a position in some
authorities but
um obviously we've not we don't want to
change our our rules
because ours are stricter obviously okay
thank you thank you johan
michael the doctor will see you now
hello um yeah i just um think you're
trying to think of vaguely creative
solutions to this
if you have any uh welcome the testing
issue i mean obviously
people are on webcam and you can see
them you know then
and you have photographic ident you know
identity
then is that one way of you know
making sure that it's um not in the in
the talking about the test now
counseling the
i mean that has been suggested that has
been suggested that they hold up
and they all will hold up um their
identification as well their driving
license or something like that
so that is a possibility that we could
look at
um alternate alternatively and you know
an interview style um
you know test i mean i know that that's
good that would be recent
personnel resource intensive but you
know if something
would and we have the problem is we have
800 people
in the you know in the various stages of
the
um processes have been suspended at the
moment so
it's a lot of drivers that might be
something for the future
you know when we've once got over that
hurdle of that that large number of
of people who are waiting um
i'm not sure as you say that the
resources would allow us to do
be able to check uh stories we'd like
um and also we'd need to involve i think
audits because obviously audit would be
concerned about us verifying people's
identity and what is the best way to do
that
um so yeah these are they're all for
consideration in my mind if we watch
that online are there any third-party
companies like you said for the um
yes they are they are um we currently um
have a company that does our dbs checks
for us because we had to go
before lockdown we would we would do
them
you know people would come in with all
their documentation and we would
manually
manually check them and then send off
the applications to the dbs and we
couldn't do that obviously
from lockdown so we have a company that
are doing the dbs checks for us and they
also do
they do knowledge tests for other
authorities
so that is again that is another um
option
although obviously we've spent a lot of
time developing our own
knowledge test and induction course um
and you know we would like to have
retained control of it so
um i think there these options all have
to be considered
as we as we move forward so um
no i haven't settled on one particular
um
option right now
thank you all right uh dan
you've got a question well yeah one of
them has just been partially covered as
i say
by the by the previous speaker in terms
of uh trying to uh alternatives to
um the texting regime whilst i can i
think
a lot of the learning should be he's
fairly easily done online i do agree
that
with doing a test online you are making
it rather easy if they do hold up their
ids to prove who they are whether how
much observation with them there
there would be of them actually
completing the test you know it would be
very easy for someone to be sort of
sitting there with sort of
a laptop looking things up and sort of
passing them the information for them to
complete it
even if they're all in a video if people
just do the sort of sitting someone
sitting next to them
just passing it over a fairly low level
of them to take crib notes from
continuously throughout the test or
something like that
uh i thought it would have been too
difficult though to get say an external
site
to go and do the test down where they
could sit far enough apart from each
other
although how relevant that is now given
the fact we're about to end all the
lockdown measurements in a in about
three months time
uh but if we wanted to make a start of
them now sugar you could just hire a
hole somewhere
and have them sitting fairly widely
spread apart
we did have a contract with um ua 92
that's where the tests
were taking place prior to lockdown the
first lockdown
um and they could host large numbers so
you know at some points we're having 50
to 100
candidates in the um in the classrooms
and obviously
that's set up in a classroom environment
so it was perfect
um you know um for for us to use so the
hope is
um even if the town hall don't open um
you know the their meeting rooms and so
on uh before september
perhaps the university will be yeah
surely four lockdown measures trend uh
of course to
end on the 21st of june which is what
the government
at least for the moment is saying
providing
it doesn't change its mind as it has
done multiple times previously why are
we waiting until september
before we're able truly if we could well
i i was going to suggest that
obviously that would be the latest and
if we can
move to um introducing something sooner
then um you know we we propose to do
that
and then i can let you know that that
that's that's
we've been it's been made possible to do
that um
sooner than september so if if we can
i i would want to certainly if we've not
got an online option and we've got we're
going back to the classroom
environment and those classrooms are
available
and um we can be assured of
because we're still going to have social
distancing rules in place for some time
i think
well i think we agree that that's going
to be a while but
that's where we're going to be as
limited the time as possible for
government saying all lock
measures are trend number two i know
there seems to be this trend to oh yes
well we everything all the science has
been fine now but let's just for the
sheer hell of it
continue the moment i think some people
are enjoying them far too much
if you ask my opinion as fast as
enjoying telling people what they must
and must not do far too much
um the other argument i will
just want to raise with you but i
appreciate that yeah in terms of the
medical
test and you get you said yeah always so
much better to get their own gp to do it
i'm not entirely certain i agree
with that my gp i haven't seen my gp
him or her whoever the hell it is for
years
i know which medical center i'm
registered with but i couldn't even
remember the name of my own doctor and
so
my doctor if i did go and see him if i
was a taxi driver if we
imagine that for a moment and i was
going to see my doctor
it'd be no better than seeing anybody
being given a potted history of my
medical
uh you know my medical details because
my doctor has no relationship with me
whatsoever now unless you're ill and
seeing them on a regular basis which i
imagine that taxi drivers is probably
not going to be the case otherwise
if there were chronic conditions that
were constantly seeing their doctor
all the time well they're probably not
really taxi drivers if they're gonna if
they're in a medical
uh bind at least most of the time anyway
surely just a doctor who's seen your
senior potted history is probably just
as good as your own gp
in my case it would be exactly the same
thing because my gp even though i might
be technically their patient
i haven't seen him in years i can't even
remember what their name is they've got
all your medical records
yeah but any doctor who's seen your
medical records
is going to be just even you could argue
if we were getting as a halfway house
any gp from your practice where you're
registered is just
because they'll have all your medical
records i mean my gp
and these days medical records can be
floated about fairly easily via an email
uh you know if a doctor was gonna carry
out a medical ex
for you all you'd have to do is email
your g your practice and say
i am due to have a medical exam of this
person for a taxi license uh can you
please provide me
and they'll be able to flip them over so
yeah your surgery to do
that wouldn't you so well surely in
these days this day and age that's not
that
it shouldn't be an issue i think it's
more of an issue
between you and your surgery we
we're perhaps assuming that oh yes dr
smith will recognize joe soap
who's going to be because he'll have
some ongoing relationship with him
these days often there's not people
don't get to see their doctors that
often i haven't seen mine in
years and don't even know what his name
is so i have so i'm assuming that's
because
there is no issue you have no issue you
know
long may that continue dan long may that
continue
i'm still you believe that i'm sure you
yes i'm sure that
all the counselors on this um on this on
this council
would hate the very idea of me being
stuck down with the lurgy tomorrow i'm
sure
you'd probably be a celebration if that
happened but i'm sure if you were your
doctors
would be all over you well whoever my
doctor is in the distance
the point is that as long as they've had
a copy of the medical records
which they will be able to confirm
that'll be first tick in the form
have you seen the medical records yes
tick if they say no well then you'd have
to reject
as soon as long as they've seen the
medical records it doesn't really matter
what doctor it is
one gp is probably pretty much as good
as another in that circumstance and that
would at least free things up
as long as they've seen the medical
records be they the gp themselves
be they another gp at the same surgery
who's gone and got them from or another
gp
wherever who's just had them sent to him
it doesn't really matter
as long as they've seen them before they
do the uh before they do
the test and just tick the box in the
form to say yes i've seen them
yeah it's not a problem with the system
i'm sure they're all overworked
especially at the moment with the kobe
my response would be my response would
be that
i agree in many cases that would be um
enough in terms of um
you know verifying that that person was
medically fit
but they're going to be occasions and
we've had them before the committee
where we've had adopt to say
well i'm not prepared to say on the
forum that they're not medical fit but i
have a concern about this driver's
drinking because
i've seen him on a number of occasions
and he has a drinking problem
um we've had that before the committee
in the past i remember the case you're
referring to
and then there are other issues where
you know um that
it all depends a lot of the time on
what's recording on that driver's record
not everything may be coded um
you know on their medical record um
properly
and a doctor that might that does have a
relationship with
a patient who they see regularly because
they have some
medical conditions might know whether
somebody
has been diagnosed um with a condition
they've been
diagnosed medication and they're not
taking that medication
for instance that might not be coded on
somebody's record so that
i think there are there is there is
value
in having um
the input from the doctor a doctor that
has seen
that driver um and we will accept
um a medical from a practice
not just that one you know you know if
you go to i go to a practice and i not
necessarily not see it
the same doctor every time i go but um
but all my records are there and can be
accessed by
surgery and we kind of would accept that
um i'm slowly arguing against yourself
here because if i'm a locum at a gp
surgery
i'm just going to be going off the
medical records now for the regular bp
he's on holiday
hasn't recorded it all down in the notes
the fact that he knows about
the fact that i'm sitting in the same
building it makes no difference it could
be any it could be a doctor across town
you know if if they haven't written it
down in the medical records and it's not
the actual gp who
knows all about this person who
remembers all about this person hasn't
bothered to write any of it in their
medical record
because he simply carries it around all
in his head
well then that's if i'm a locum at the
same
same practice covering him while he's on
holiday
well then it'd be in exactly the same
situation that's just human error it
could happen
anywhere it's not fulfilled but then
then surely doctors should be
recording the media
simon simon thomas you have a question
yes certainly um
on the on the doctor's access anyone
who's got access to the nhs name
mainframe as a doctor can access through
your own nhs number
and they can see the records and most
doctors nowadays do
complete and comply with the record
keeping well that's the point
i i do i do say that that but private
doctors don't
for that matter you would have to get uh
you'd have to give permission for them
to access
uh my question is obviously we're
looking at till
uh september now
two parts password if the lockdown or
the roadmap
is successful in what he wants to
achieve by the
21st of june can we can we look at it
and shorten that period
but also um there is no guarantee
and uh the prime minister said this
himself that the 21st of june
is the the supposed holy grail for
the removal of any um
distancing or lockdown measures
obviously
all depends on what happens going
forward
over the next couple of months so i
think the 20
the september idea is is a good idea but
i just do wonder that
uh if by
following the road map and things pan
out the way that's supposed to pan out
that uh if we can we can bring you
forward obviously
there is also the flip side where we may
have to extend it
uh can we bring it forward
as i responded to council bunting
earlier i think um
that there is that option yes i mean
that would be we could review it
um at any time up to um september
um obviously our ambition is to
um try and restart the the um
testing as soon as we can um safely
um so i think um if
there is an option to to to start those
tests again
sooner then i would propose to come back
to you and say can we start sooner than
that
we may even say as an emergency kind of
decision we can obviously
approach the chair and say we can start
from that date but it's sooner than the
next committee meeting is that okay and
then we can report back to
the committee that we've actually
started the tests um
um anticipated so yeah that that that
would not
you know that this decision today
wouldn't stop um
officers from still um pursuing um
them starting the tests at an earlier
date if we can
in that case and i i i would propose
that we support the
uh the achievement from the vote
a suggestion based on a combination of
council thomas's argument and my own
if we are going to restart earlier if
possible
and we're going to need a period of time
post lockdown completing
of however many weeks in order to put
various measures in place
to start again could you not remove a
date and simply say
post lock whatever the lockdown ends
whether
you say is the 21st of june x weeks post
that
and that way if it were to be pushed
back
i take longer then you would have
automatically longer
without the need to come back to anyone
because it would say lock down plus so
many weeks
or if it were brought forward then the
same would apply in other words you know
if i brought it
to the beginning of june for argument's
sake then you'd say well okay you've
acquired two three weeks whatever it is
to get yourself back up to
get things in place so whatever lockdown
is plus x days
and that's when you'd start from and
that would avoid the need for you to
come back
at all because it will be a floating
date that would would give you the
flexibility you need
i just think i just think it's simpler
to actually have
a date by which um we would review
things um i just find
that it may complicate things if we're
you know that that idea um i mean
that's the reason we put a date is
because legal say we can't just have an
open-ended
and you wouldn't with this situation
you'd have a date but it would avoid
your need to come back to mitigate it or
you'll need to go to the chairman or
whatever it would be
because that would simply say okay you
require one slot down finishes you need
two weeks to get yourself
to do the necessary work required to put
yourselves in a position to go ahead and
do that
so okay if you say lockdown plus two
weeks say is
uh december uh not december sorry june
21st
well okay two weeks from june 21st to
start if it's delayed to august 21st
well okay fine no problem two two weeks
from that day he's only
it wouldn't or if it came forward it
would make it easier it wouldn't be that
complicated at all
to be saying lockdown ends plus x days
that would be
fairly clear and straightforward
because because it might be that we come
out as i say to you it might be that we
come out of
you know the idea is 21st of june but we
don't know at that stage whether or not
there would still be requirements around
social distancing
no no they've said end of all lockdown
measures
that's not well let's all start wearing
face masks and that's all
that that is what they said what they're
taking i'm taking the government
at their word they have said end of
lockdown measures
that means the end of lockdown measures
not the partial
end i think partial updates
yeah given before then i think we need
to allow it to bed in
i mean we're having we'll be having a
meeting before the end of september
three week third week of september we
can review it then
to obviously see how we how we go
forward
you know so i think i think we need to
see
it see how it goes i mean nothing's
going to happen over summer anyway
really because people be going on
holiday
i mean i don't even know whether
hopefully you're having a regular
meeting well possibly it depends if i
haven't got like the idea or not
well i know it's it it's data not dates
but
as we keep being told but i i think we
need a target date
we'll we'll aim for that date and we
will we'll see it we'll see how it goes
on that date but i think we do need to
address
with the with the the officers how are
we are we address the backlog really
going forward because there's a
there's obviously going to be a huge
backlog of applicants and i think that's
another
discussion really between the officers
and the politicians really
how we address that but i think it is
fair enough that we have a target date
summer will go past in a flash as it
always does
and i think as long as we know that
we're going to review it on the at the
end of september
and then then i think that'll give us
the time time for everything to bed in
and we can we can look at the data and
see how it goes and not rush into
you know being held to making a decision
yeah i agree dave i mean although
council blunton's uh
idea is perhaps in a utopian that's how
we come out lockdown
that would be a good idea it is flexible
we've been told at every press
conference virtually how flexibility is
so we don't
as joanne says we don't know how we're
going to come out lockdown
there could be measures from june the
21st although we may be allowed to go on
holiday or
go to the pub or eat in a restaurant or
whatever we may want to do
we don't know and that that that's why i
think that
as it stands i i propose that we support
that
and we we take it as it comes and if
there's need for
extra dialogue then that should that
should come as and when it's
uh available so is that a proposal
recommendation i'll second that
are we happy to vote on it yeah
yeah how do we do this just raise your
hand
on on camera generally go go round it or
i'm happy to right hand i mean if we
need to we'll do it virtually but
okay yeah i'm prepared to support it
with a substantial degree of reluctance
i do think we are getting a degree of
mission creep coming in here
okay that's noted all right we'll
we'll agree that the recommendations in
in the report okay so any
urgent business in the open section
no chair can i move the exclusion
resolution
okay well in that case i'll officially
close the meeting
and thank everybody for their attendance